good more to believe nation today's
messages execute your dream over to you
any Murphy I don't want to be in show
business
and I just happened to luck out and
things happen I think you know you know
you if you you know what you're supposed
to do deep down inside I think everybody
does a lot of people just don't go after
it you know it like most people start
out they say I want to be as this but
I'm gonna give that to make sure I have
something to fall back on and what
you're doing is you setting yourself up
a fake cuz you're going there's a
possibility that i'ma fall back and when
you put that out there then you fall
back but if you just say hey this is
what I want to do and you go do it you
usually get your stuff the way you want
it man that's what thank you guys so
much for watching the question of the
day today is what is preventing you from
executing your true big dream what's
holding you back
leaving the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout to lead gen you thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
VESA
what's up believe nation if you want a
little more motivation on executing your
dreams stay tuned for some bonus clips
my assistants got a great thing now in
this once in every four months somebody
sends an email saying I've got a huge
startup that I want you to invest in but
you've gotta sign this NDA right which
literally every time gets an email back
that says [ __ ] you right and and the
reason is I'm a humongous believer that
ideas are [ __ ] and that executions the
game right we've all got ideas
everybody's got ideas doing ideas we all
have here we could probably sit here for
the next two hours draw them all out
record them and predict the next 78
great startups over the next nine years
and so I think the thing that is another
theme in entrepreneurship is there is
way too much fodder brought to the idea
uber was magic cab three years earlier
uber is not an idea uber existed it's
called magic cab but the guys that
execute it sucked so they lost so I
think you know if there's any level of
romance left in this room about your
idea
I'd like to suffocate it because I think
the actual situation is what you
actually do with it the way of the
entrepreneur is is actually about going
looking at the world and finding
problems it's actually some people think
that's a negative mindset but actually I
find it as like a it's like it's a
curious mindset is you're out there
looking for problems looking for things
that aren't the way they should be or
could be okay you got a good idea look
everybody's got a good idea yeah you
know now the okay everybody has an idea
not everybody has been a good idea but
people have good ideas look Buber is a
good idea you push a button and get a
ride I don't know if we were the first
person to ever think of that idea but we
were the first person to do it and and
so you got to just go do it then you've
got to just get out there and go do it
so it's easy to have the idea or
straightforward but then you've got to
have enough guts to go out there and try
and that's that's the way of the
entrepreneur I think you famously said
strategy is 5% of the answer and
execution is 95% so so what does that
mean and how did you actually what did
you do differently but you know the 5%
yeah I said yeah 5% of the challenge is
strategy 95% of the execution this I
said it as CEO of Nissan I said it also
a CEO of Renault and I said it as deputy
CEO of Renault when I said the first
time it was mainly in France and I was
to my to the top management of Renault
in France because there was a tendency
in the company to spend too much time on
strategy and leave the execution for
other people and this is where I said
yeah strategy is fine it's very
important but it's only 5% if you don't
go to execution after this the the
delivery and the performance of the
company is going to be very weak I
really I really believe it now it
doesn't mean strategy is not important
but when you establish north and you
know exactly where North is for the
company you've done something very
important because you're giving the
direction but if you don't start moving
north if you don't start mapping and
establishing milestone you know you're
never gonna be getting there you're
never gonna be getting there execute and
you need to execute as fast as possible
because the thing at the end today is
whether you feel you have competitors or
not sooner or later you're gonna have
someone and if you can't move fast
enough
someone's gonna beat you to the punch so
make sure whatever you're doing you get
something out within a month or two if
it takes you longer than that you're
taking way too long
I created this company called surf and
it was in Rockwall Texas right by Dallas
and I had this brilliant idea have any
of you guys heard of the media temple
grid server solution that was my idea a
year or two before it came out and I
spent a million bucks on it trying to
actually do that idea before media
temple was funny thing is that I have a
million bucks so actually had a borrow a
million bucks and I sped it spent out on
business partners who moved
really slow and really weren't the best
at what they did within 12 months we
launched nothing they also had some of
the Proms in my previous slide right
like financial instability and they had
a family and kids of I think like six
so even bottom my home in Rockwall Texas
that cost two hundred and something
thousand why did I buy it instead of
renting it I have no clue Oh stupid and
young but nonetheless I lost over a
million bucks on that a borrowed money
not investor money but borrowed money
that I had to pay back and it failed
miserably because we never launched
anything if you can't along something
someone like media tumbles gonna beat
you to the punch
get a ton of customers and make a lot of
money so lessons I learned from that set
deadlines no matter what you have to set
deadlines people have to be held
accountable to him as well right
can't just set deadlines it passes
nothing happens someone better be
meeting him if not you know something
has to change you also need to make sure
they're small if the deadline if the
like milestones goals are too big for
those deadlines they're not gonna get
met so make them really small and
tangible that way you can see it really
well in advance if they're actually
gonna be met or not and last but not
least don't worry about perfection a lot
of people like dude I'm gonna create the
most perfect version of you know
whatever it may be that software has a
lot of bugs nothing's gonna be perfect
perfection is overrated nothing's ever
perfect you're gonna continue to have to
iterate so forth so on it's never gonna
be perfect there's always gonna be
issues just get it out there and start
trying to make money well the last and
the most valuable lesson as an
entrepreneur I learned was about the
value of execution we're too many people
we're too many people spend too much
time thinking about the vision we are
taught that you have to build a better
mousetrap every venture capitals will
tell you that to be a successful
entrepreneur you need a breakthrough
innovation well you have to assume none
of us or at least most of us are not the
smartest people in the world there are
lots and lots of great great
inventors are there how are we going to
be the person who's going to always
build a better mousetrap well to be
successful you don't have to build a
better mousetrap you just have to build
a different mousetrap and as long as you
are executing well the business always
comes down to block and tackle it's not
about the great vision it's always about
the great execution and you can always
succeed by out executing your
competitors not necessarily having the
best product in the marketplace and I
think the Microsoft is a great example
where they took a same product that
other people may have had but they
executed is substantially better and
today the market leader in the industry